all right famous and fashionable hit the
links Pebble Beach this weekend a sight
to be seen and another one people talk
about culture this week in Olivia it was
all about the cars instead the jet set
they're looking the most expensive cars
in the world the pebble beach concours
d'elegance bloomberg pursuits reporter
Hannah Elliott rub shoulders the creme
de la creme of classic car collectors
she joins us from Carmel I left I was
there this weekend but just amazing
among all of these cars a lot of serious
car collectors a lot of gearheads was
Jay Leno there I heard Jerry Seinfeld
was around we had so we had some big
names there that's right Jay Leno was
there he was at a dinner for Mercedes
the night before and then of course we
saw him on the Concorde he is kind of
the the grandfather of events de facto
of course but in past years we've had
Arnold Schwarzenegger Ralph Lauren Jerry
Seinfeld of course they're the regular
car guys you'd expect to see plus a lot
of very well-known collectors within the
industry and a lot of sick cars a lot of
cigars Hannah which were the hottest
models this year the Ferraris of course
everyone expects this and we're kind of
just waiting ok when is this Ferrari
craze going to end it's still the
Ferraris as of last night's auctions of
the top 10 sellers seven were Ferraris
again so the Ferrari craze is still
there again it's the 250th ferrari 250 s
in the early 60s 1962 1964 yeah i saw
1960 ferrari 250 that was parked out if
I said whoever did a radio broadcast
last week and the short wheel and it was
just but so many cars me I can't
possibly describe this event where it
looked when someone pulled up in like a
current day poor show or a fabulous like
audi or BMW it looked like a [ __ ] car
you might as well pulled up in a Ford
f-150 it's it's true I mean you get used
to seeing Bentley's Rolls Royces Jaguars
they're just street parked and no one
even bats an eye I mean this those are
very very ho-hum compared to what we see
here I had
in this year's auction stack up two
years past you know stock markets while
flat this year are near record highs our
prices for classic cars higher than ever
they are we you know I just talked with
Haggerty this morning we're just getting
final results from last night's auctions
but preliminary results say the total
for the whole weekend is about four
hundred million dollars for all auctions
last year was 415 million so it's
generally in the same area will get
final numbers later this week growth is
still there still maximum prices 17
million for the highest cars but it's
it's calming a little bit interesting so
that little there was talk of a 500
million dollar a handle on the week and
I guess we didn't get there so that's
interesting to me but they also the car
show right which is big part of this who
was the winner this year of course
winners can't repeat so it's a new car
winning at least what was it right it's
a 1924 asada franchini tipo 8a this is a
very rare car it had been in france and
switzerland until last year its had only
four owners incident in its entire life
the owner now is jim patterson of
Louisville Kentucky very special
cabriole a coach work inside very rare
very expensive is a country custom car
was made wasn't made for the original
owner yes that is correct and that's one
of the reasons again why it's so special
it's basically one of a kind